hola qué tal muy buen día sin duda las
fracturas dentro de la oposición y la
falta de consenso para poder lograr
candidaturas únicas de cara a estos
comicios regionales le pasó factura a la
oposición la brecha en algunos estados
fue muy corta y la suma de los votos
entre los distintos candidatos
opositores le habría dado el triunfo en
al menos tres gobernaciones más llama la
atención además que los únicos tres
políticos que ganaron las gobernaciones
de oposición no corresponden a
liderazgos emergentes a nuevos
liderazgos por el contrario son personas
que ya habían ganado estas gobernaciones
en venezuela hace 25 años porque por lo
que el objetivo de renovar estos
liderazgos dentro de la propia oposición
claramente tampoco se logró ha habido
algunos pronunciamientos a través de
redes sociales de dirigentes opositores
muy pocos la verdad donde han hecho me
ha culpa y reflexionado y aceptado que
fue un error haber ido de sumidos a
estos comicios regionales también habla
una alta abstención más del 58 por
ciento por lo que no lograron tampoco
convencer a los ciudadanos de acudir
masiva a las urnas aunque la
participación según las encuestadoras
era la estimada para este tipo de
comicios se logró ya como decías una
participación del 41% se consolida así
el gobierno el chavismo con 20 de las 23
gobernaciones ahora daniela también se
ha denunciaron irregularidades durante
esta jornada electoral de ayer domingo
que puede decirnos de estos
señalamientos
una de las principales denuncias fue
cuando ya tocaba la hora de los cierres
de los centros electorales a las seis de
la tarde -hora local- según reglamento
siempre y cuando no haya electores en
fila pasada esta hora incluso el propio
nicolás maduro llamaba a la operación
remate es decir que llevaron a los
electores a las urnas para continuar con
el proceso de votación en algunos centro
de votaciones y todavía llegaban
electores pero había otros donde no
había nadie afuera y los centros se
mantenían abiertos otras de las
irregularidades que se denunció fue la
actuación de estos denominados
colectivos grupos armados al margen de
la ley que apoyan el gobierno que
amedrentaron a ciudadanos a votantes e
incluso también a candidatos que
denunciaron que fueron golpeados en los
centros de votación y por supuesto el
fatídico incidente en el estado zulia
donde una persona resultó fallecida
aunque a juicio el ministro defensa esto
se trató de un hecho aislado